[Música]
a
a los 4 años soñaba con ser negra eso
cuentan mis papás
a esa edad en la que todos somos
inocentes y soñadores sin límites
yo soñaba con ese continente y empezó a
importarme tanto áfrica cuando ni
siquiera sabía dónde quedaba
el porqué tardé mucho tiempo en
descubrir
quien es de los que están aquí
cumplieron algunos de sus sueños que
tenían a los cuatro cinco o seis años
probablemente si os hubiera pasado hoy
tendríamos una sobrepoblación de
astronautas veterinarios o algo por el
estilo
pero llega ese momento en que a los 4
años se toma coraje porque si a los 4
años también se puede tener coraje y se
comparte ese sueño con alguien más un
adulto
y esa respuesta que se recibe s si usted
puede hacer lo que quiera s ya se le va
a pasar eso es un capricho ese hay hay
cosas que tienen más futuro esa
respuesta puede marcar el inicio o el
fin de un sueño de un futuro de una vida
plena o de muchas vidas plenas
para mí el coraje es ese valor y esa
decisión que se toma cuando algo le
apasiona a uno mucho y hace que un sueño
dejó de ser sueño y se convierta en un
propósito de vida
en mi caso una cifra hizo que áfrica
dejará de ser un sueño y se convirtiera
en un propósito de vida que inclusive
podía llegar a salvar muchas vidas
una cifra un 75% me hizo tener el coraje
de arriesgar ese 75% lo descubrí
mientras leía un proyecto de tesis de
una costa licencia que tenía ya 12 años
de estar trabajando en etiopía como
directora de una clínica
ella se encontraba en costa rica
cursando una maestría en pediatría con
el fin de llevar herramientas que le
pudieran ayudar aquí y aquí
para poder reducir a que el 75 por
ciento que reflejaba el índice de
mortalidad infantil en hardware etiopía
ese 75% significaba la cantidad de niños
y niñas que morían por causas que en su
mayoría podrían evitarse una diabetes
una tos una gripe cosas de estas que
aquí
cuando regrese a mi casa después de leer
esa tesis me preguntaba muchísimo que
estaba pasando en costa rica y volvía a
ver a mi país y decía cómo será ese
índice aquí y cuál será el porcentaje me
preguntaba muchísimas cosas me puse a
investigar y descubrí que en costa rica
es el 8% el índice de mortalidad
infantil el 8% yo no podía creer esa
diferencia tan abismal
y seguían las confrontaciones y yo me
preguntaba qué se podía hacer por ese
75% y no sólo que se podía sino que
quería y que estaba dispuesto a hacer
en ese momento de muchas confrontaciones
yo claramente ya no tenía cuatro años
pero sí tenía una amiga que estuvo
dispuesta y que tuvo el coraje para
decir hagamos algo y ahí nació a crítica
a críticas un canal de impulso y
esperanza para proyectos de acción
social en áfrica desde costa rica por lo
que también podríamos decir que el
coraje significa crítica
y es que claro para tener coraje hay que
estar dispuesto a todo inclusive al
dolor y a la muerte
llegó uno de los días en los que me
encontraba en etiopía justamente en esta
clínica de hardware
yo comí gavazzi está blanca no dirigía
como buena mañana a trabajar en el
laboratorio ayudar al micro biólogo con
todas las muestras que se tenían que
procesar todo parecía ir normal
hasta que uno de los enfermeros se me
acerca y me dice acabamos de recibir a
un bebé de tan sólo cuatro días de
nacido en un estado de malnutrición
severo
y ahí empecé yo a luchar contracorriente
para los enfermeros era muy claro
qué iba a pasar cómo iba a pasar y en
qué momento iba a pasar pero para mí
en la esperanza que me generaba mi
propia inexperiencia era impensable que
aquello pudiera pasar insistí muchísimo
y empezó una lucha de los enfermeros y
una lucha personal
que también hizo que ese bebé luchara
pero la realidad fue muy distinta a los
deseos que teníamos en ese momento ya
que el hombrecito de tan solo cuatro
días de nacido
yo no sé cómo se sientan ustedes ahorita
pero yo en ese momento y también un
poquito ahora
sentí muchísimo dolor y muchísima cólera
yo no podía entender como aquello pasaba
en mis manos sin que yo pudiera hacer
nada
como un bebé estaba muriendo porque su
mamá no supo cómo darle de mamar
y en ese momento
en medio de la cólera y yo preguntaba
las muchas veces que nos han cuestionado
porque áfrica y por qué no costa rica
y esa pregunta andaba ahí porque irse a
desacomodar allá cuando aquí hay muchas
necesidades
pero es que mi comodidad estaba ahí
pero es que cuando volvía la mirada
crítica' y pensaba en los retos y en los
sacrificios que todos hemos tenido que
hacer confirmaba porque nos habíamos
propuesto ser un canal de impulso y de
esperanza
y es que para tener coraje hay que tener
conciencia y para arriesgar
definitivamente hay que prepararse
un amigo que ha dado su vida por áfrica
me dijo una vez
lori con áfrica no se juega
y ahí yo entendí que para abrazar y para
amar a áfrica necesitaba conocerla
necesitaba entender la
necesitaba estar preparada para la vida
inclusive para la muerte
pero la verdad es que nunca se está
completamente preparado
a que el bebé de tan sólo cuatro días
fue la dosis de coraje que yo necesitaba
para cumplir el objetivo por el cual me
encontraba en etiopía y era el
equipamiento de cinco centros de salud
en la zona de hardware con el propósito
de acercar la consulta médica a las
zonas de mayor población
por este proyecto habíamos trabajado dos
años enteros
todos en áfrica habíamos sacrificado por
amor a la causa habíamos empezado a
luchar y ver cómo generamos donaciones y
de repente estábamos convertidos en
artesanos creando productos y collares y
una y otra cosa para ir generando poco a
poco los fondos que iban equipando cada
centro los fondos que iban comprando
cada camilla cada doble el casi tus
completos estas cosas necesarias en un
centro de salud
está en realidad no fue nuestro primer
proyecto
el primero años atrás fue la creación de
una sala de internación esta sala
básicamente que atendía a los pacientes
con enfermedades más severas y les daba
seguimiento en el tratamiento y no sólo
esto sino que también acogía a sus
familias para hacer como un proceso de
capacitación
entonces les enseñaba qué cambios debían
darse en su estilo de vida en su
alimentación en todo esto
esta sala no solo nos hizo sentir que si
se podía y que si podíamos
esta sala fue el escenario de una
historia de la vida real en la que si se
puede salvar vidas en las que a crítica
empezó a salvar vidas
esta sala nos regaló la vida de ministro
me he visto a sus siete años
de la último del último hospital que
visitó lo mandaron a morir a su casa
le dijeron a sus papás el estado muy
severo no sabemos que tiene pero es muy
severo
lo mejor es que los últimos días es
fácil con él en casa tranquilos todos
juntos unidos
ese fue el mismo diagnóstico de los
últimos cuatro centros donde él había
estado
una vecina llegó y le dijo por qué no
van hay una clínica pequeñita en harvard
intenten sería la última oportunidad
ellos hicieron caso fueron en cuestión
de minutos
se dieron cuenta que lo que me gustó
tenía era una diabetes
que nunca se había podido diagnosticar
en ese momento la clínica la tenía
apenas tres semanas de haber estrenado
creado la sala de internación
esta sala fue la casa de ministro y de
su familia durante tres meses allí les
enseñaron cómo inyectarse la insulina
cómo debían cambiar los estilos de
alimentación
todos estos cambios empezaron a dar mí y
esto iba mejorando mes a mes día a día
y a los tres meses lo mandaron a su casa
a vivir a los tres meses le dieron a sus
padres se lo pueden llevar para que lo
disfruten años a los tres meses ni esto
salió para ir a la escuela y ser un niño
como lo era antes de ese diagnóstico
hoy son 5400 ministros
hoy son 5 mil 400 personas las que mes a
mes se atienden en la clínica central y
en los 5 centros de salud que se
terminaron equipando
esos 5 mil 400 personas nos hicieron
entender que realmente nunca hubo una
distancia entre áfrica y costa rica
porque esos 5 mil 400 personas nos
hicieron sentir parte de áfrica
el año pasado fueron 64 mil 800 personas
las que se atendieron
es que pudieron ir y tener sus bebés y
que ya no tuviera este problema de que
no se sabía dar de mamar porque ahí les
enseñaban
porque a ellos se pueden diagnosticar
diabetes en cuestión de minutos
o tifoidea y darse los tratamientos
esas 64 1800 personas eran nuestra
responsabilidad son nuestra
responsabilidad su vida estaba de una u
otra manera en nuestras manos
y ahí entendíamos las palabras de olga
la que era directora de la clínica en
etiopía cuando nos decía todos tenemos
un compromiso ético con el otro
principalmente cuando está en juego su
vida
y es que aquel 75 que yo había leído en
el 2014 ya no es el mismo y es que
nosotros tampoco somos los mismos
esas vidas nos cambiaron esas vidas nos
dieron vida
hoy el índice de mortalidad infantil es
de un 59% en etiopía y la verdad yo no
sé si al menos un 0.01 por ciento de ese
índice o de esa producción tuvo que ver
o no crítica no lo sé
lo que sé es que estas vidas siguen
estando en nuestras manos lo que sé es
que esas personas que mensualmente
reciben atención médica son el impulso y
la razón por la cual día a día pensamos
que hacer
por mejorar la calidad de vida por abrir
oportunidades para las personas de
áfrica
ellas nos dan el impulso para seguir
luchando por este programa que ahora
tenemos de educación para la mujer en
mozambique y en sur sudán ellas son las
que nos impulsan a seguir teniendo este
coraje de arriesgar
quienes de ustedes están dispuestos a
arriesgarlo todo por un sueño inocente
por un sueño que no ha tenido un proceso
de viabilidad con indicadores de
imposible logro
quienes están dispuestos a apoyar
sueños inocentes
yo personalmente le agradezco esa niña
de 4 años por haber tenido ese sueño
por haber soñado con áfrica
porque esa niña me lleva me enlisto
y me gustó me hizo sentir verdaderamente
viva
y esto me hizo sentir
que valía la pena arriesgar
aquel bebé
de cuatro días de nacido
y me en gusto
le dieron razón a mi vida y le dieron es
una crítica a ambos me hicieron sentir
parte de áfrica
su muerte me dolía
y su vida me llenaba de gratitud
pero ambos por fin me hicieron sentir
negra muchas gracias
[Aplausos]